there's been very little difference
between the printed calendar the analog
calendar and the digital calendar other
than the migration to the digital space
you go back 5 years uh and you know
people some people weren't even
comfortable emailing with each other and
5 years before that most people didn't
email with each other we've seen huge
changes in communication Platforms in
publishing platforms we've seen huge
changes in the way in which we connect
with people the calendar has stayed
static for 500 years if not more so the
industry in the early '90s was just
starting to recognize calendaring the
only Innovation that really happened is
people took these calendars and brought
it on the web you look at the Outlook
you look at Google uh Lotus Notes pretty
much the same thing for for office now
so if you either you have your weekly
view daily view or monthly view but it's
it's a table basically uh it works for
most for some people uh doesn't work for
for for a bunch of other people I look
back and go add 20 you know go back 20
years and you look at say what was the
real limiting factor for people who were
pushing their professional envelope it
was what technology could get could you
put in their hands how do you actually
make them more effective by giving them
technology now the floodgates have
opened you I've got the Blackberry I've
got the the iPhone I've got the iPad
I've got the laptop I've got the desktop
and then the list goes on I think the
biggest value of digital calendaring
over wall calendar is that when I'm
walking on the street
my phone will tell me that I'm missing
something I need to go somewhere I need
to you know that having that just in
time is amazingly moms and dads
everywhere have always done that it's
been on the kitchen refrigerator and
instead now it's on you know Google or
Yahoo or some service like that there
are three or four companies that really
jumped on that in the past three years
um that so that's a relatively new
phenomenon in the past three years um
done a pretty good job of solving that
problem uh but you guys are really
thinking much further ahead than anyone
else that uh that I've seen in the space
because we can never get more time the
calendar of the future should help me to
optimize the way I spend my time so I
can get more accomplished in a day 5
years from now booking time with your
dentist is going to be on your calendar
and in fact it's it's going to happen
from your phone it's almost a tear down
reild in terms of UI how do you take a
fresh eye to it and come up with
something that's that's
a you click on it it zooms and it has
pictures and it has interactivity
absolutely has Beauty to it it has to no
longer be a now I go to my calendar and
think about
calendaring I have to really get to a
place where it is seamlessly woven into
the other tasks that I'm doing
discovering events uh in your
neighborhood I think when we talk to
users about that it's something that
they really get excited about
availability should be uh should be
something we use more the calendar of
the future optimizes my time and as a
result it optimizes my life I can go and
I can say some algorithm will just tell
me what to do I don't think that's
coming anytime soon it may happen in a
very narrow scope where there's a you
know a defined set of Acts and I can
tell you which one of three but I'm not
going to walk in the office on Monday
and have some system tell me what I
should do Monday through Friday calendar
usage is is going up very fast the
calendar of the future is not so far
away too many companies startups
particularly focus on features and
functions today and they're not telling
their vision for the future and that's
you know that's a differentiating factor
can you uh you like this Vision I do
yeah I think it's great cool
yeah